Let's see which of these ordered pairs matches with these points. For negative 4
0 we start at the origin and count negative 4 in the x direction and 0 in the y
direction and that leads us to point f. So f is the answer to the first problem.
For 3, -2, we know we're going to go 3 in the X direction and -2 in the Y
direction. So we start at the origin and we count 3, 1, 2, 3 and -2 in the y
direction means we move down, 1, 2, so we get to point A. For negative 3, 4,
negative 3 in the x-direction, 4 in the y-direction. So we start at the origin.
Negative 3 for x, 1, 2, 3, positive 4 for y, 1, 2, 3, 4, leads us to point c. 4,
3, means 4 in the x-direction, 1, 2, 3, 4, and 3 in the y-direction, 1, 2, 3,
leads us to point b. And 0, 2 means 0 in the x-direction so that means we don't
go left or right at all. And we simply go up to 1, 2 leads us to point D. And
for the last one, negative 2, negative 3, means we go negative 2 in the x
direction, negative 3 in the y direction, which leads us to point E. If you got
those right, you did a wonderful job. Let's do something a little different.